[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: You've got
data and you know how
to get it into Cloud Storage.
Now let's talk about who you
want to have access to it.
I'm in a sharing
mood, so I'll give you
permission to learn more.
Today on Cloud Storage
Bytes we're talking
about controlling access--
keeping the right people in
the loop and the wrong people
out of it.
Let's dive in.
When you first create
a bucket, you'll
need to decide whether you
want to apply permissions using
uniform or fine grained access.
In general, we recommend using
uniform bucket-level access.
This method allows
you to use IAM
to manage all of
your permissions
for all of the
objects in a bucket.
This might mean rethinking how
you are picturing your storage
approach.
Let's imagine you
run a dog daycare
and you take photos
of the dogs every day
so their owners
can log in and see
what their pet has been up to.
If you have a bucket
of photos where you're
storing all of
those, then you would
need to set the permissions
for each individual photo
so that you aren't sharing
Remy's photos with Willow's
owner.
If, however, you create
a bucket for each owner,
then you can grant
permissions for that bucket,
lowering the risk
of data exposure.
Now, if Willow's owner adds a
second person to the account,
one permission change will
share all of Willow's photos.
That's because IAM aims
to make authentication
easier by giving you full
control and visibility.
Cloud IAM provides
a unified view
into the security control
of your entire organization
across your various
Google Cloud Services.
This means there's
one place to check
for granting and
reviewing permissions
for employees, dog owners,
visitors, other franchise
locations, and more.
So that's how uniform access
works for Cloud Storage.
If, however, you
know you're going
to need to manage permissions
at the object level for a given
bucket, then you can
select fine grained access.
This option is mainly
for integrations
that rely on legacy
access control
systems for interoperability
with other services.
In addition to choosing between
uniform and fine grained access
when creating your
bucket, you also
have options for
special controls,
such as signed
URLs for accessing
an object through a link
for a set amount of time,
or signed policy
documents to specify
what can be uploaded to a
bucket, or credential access
boundaries to restrict
the permissions that
are available to an
OAuth 2.0 access token.
To learn more about
these options,
be sure to check out
the documentation.
And don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and let us know what features
of Cloud Storage you'd
like to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of Cloud Storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]